the views and opinions expressed on this
program
are those of the guests appearing on the
program and do not necessarily reflect
the views and opinions of eight news now
or next our media group
the pace has picked up considerably
we're getting to the finish line
down to the final days we explore new
laws created by the legislature and the
work left as the session ends
there's been numerous policy changes and
yes they are working
police reform metro police talks about
changes they've made while state
lawmakers passed their own measures
it was just horrific and it just breaks
your heart
wild horses sold for slaughter the
i-team investigates a federal adoption
program
from eight news now this is politics now
the final days of the 2021 legislative
session are here
thank you for joining us on politics now
i'm john langler so the session ends
monday night there is still a lot of
voting and negotiating to be done in
carson city
for example one law that has already
been signed
hush payments no longer going to keep
victims of sexual harassment or
discrimination quiet the governor signed
assembly bill 60 into law
it voids nondisclosure agreements if
they're covering up a crime or
discrimination
it was those type of agreements that
disgraced movie producer harvey
weinstein steve wynn
had his accuser assigned had their
accuser assigned it takes effect
immediately
also assigned in carson city people with
drug convictions will soon be able to
get state benefits for food and child
care governor sysolak signed assembly
bill 138 this week
it reverses state law which had kept
people
convicted of drug dealing crimes from
family or food assistance programs
that kicks in july first the off again
on again film tax credit legislation is
now on again
assembly bill 20 is now law in its
previous incarnation the tax credit
funded movies like
paul blart 2. sports and events are not
eligible for the tax credit
60 percent of a budget on a movie has to
be spent in nevada in order to qualify
for the credit
nevada is one step closer to becoming
the first state to vote in the next
presidential election in the primaries
a bill to move nevada from first in the
west to first in the country
passed the assembly this week it also
switches nevada from a caucus to a
primary setup
the bill is now heading over to the
state senate a separate bill that would
mail a ballot to voters every election
period
also passed the assembly voters would
have to opt
out of mail-in ballots you would
automatically get one
a group of strange bedfellows have
gotten together to oppose some proposed
gun control legislation
senate bill 452 is proposed by senate
majority leader nicole canezzaro
it creates criminal penalties for people
who carry a gun into a business where
there is a no guns allowed sign
democratic groups like the aclu oppose
it they say it would cause minorities to
have more
tense and dangerous interactions with
police republican groups like the nevada
firearms coalition
also oppose it they say trespassing laws
already accomplished the same thing
now this measure has narrowly passed the
senate 11 to 10
and now heads over to the state assembly
so bottom line is
there is still a lot of work left to get
done and not a lot of time
we spoke with republican assembly
minority floor leader tom roberts about
what to expect in the final days
it's really started slow uh the session
we
were slow on getting bills introduced uh
slow on moving bills
uh and uh there's been quite a bit of
log jam
here here at the end uh where we're
we're moving a lot of bills in a short
amount of time
which which is always the case with when
you only have 120 days it seems like
it's rushed
this time it seems like there are a lot
a lot more bills that are
that are still out there that we're
still working on as we get close to the
deadline
so i think it's a a little worse than it
has been before
but you know we're picking up steam and
then you know we're heading to the
finish line now
you envisioned a special session i
believe we're gonna have to have a
special session for a couple reasons i
don't
not because we didn't get the work done
here the uh
american rescue plan money that is
coming
we've gotten preliminary guidance but i
believe that
to to move some of those funds once we
get them we'll probably have to come
session i don't believe the interim
finance committee can do all that on
their own
uh and then redistricting because the
census data
probably won't be available until august
or
september we will have to have a special
session
to do redistricting a lot of talk at the
beginning of the session had to do with
especially from republicans up there uh
election reform
uh the mail-in balloting that we saw in
2020 um
are you confident that what has happened
so far in the session
will ensure a a proper election next
time around
so speaker fryerson has a bill we
actually it was actually voted out last
night
assembly bill 321 i believe i believe it
is
uh it is his omnibus uh election reform
bill
he's got a lot of good things in there
uh but there's still some things that
concern us
um what concerns you well an all mail in
uh ballot in some of the ballot
harvesting issues
uh i you know are concerns for us uh
there's a cost associated to all mail in
ballots
you know rather there's an opt-out uh
portion which
which could reduce your cost but you
know in our opinion you know mailing a
lot of ballots that aren't
aren't going to get used the last
election cycle only 38 percent of those
ballots were actually mailed in you know
at a huge
cost to taxpayers i think we could do it
uh cheaper or you phase it in over time
to allow people to get used to the
system you work out some of the bugs
and so that people have faith faith in
the system the ballot harvesting issue
which i believe uh could be or might be
watered down and we're still working on
that we're going to work on that in the
other house with the speaker
you know i can't go to a polling place
as an elected official with my campaign
shirt on
but i could certainly show up to your
house knock on your door and collect
your ballot
uh the way it was during the pandemic
the last election
he's putting some safeguards in there
there's still some things that we
will work out but look you know if
there's a significant part of the
population
that doesn't have faith and trust in our
election system
i think it it is real and we we need to
address those concerns
is enough being done to get dieter
into the present we just passed an
appropriation with
uh rescue plan money for 43 million
dollars to upgrade their
computer system that's that's the first
shot of money for that
the disappointing part is it's going to
take time to implement that
i mean we've we and during the special
session
we uh passed legislation to allow them
flexibility to address
the backlog of claims uh we've given
them
additional people we've done a number of
things
and they still struggle with
with delivering you know uh
their services to the people that need
them i still get some calls
uh you know but not quite as many as i
did before
very frustrated with it
and again that was assemblyman tom
roberts now we should point out governor
sisselak has not used his veto pen yet
during the legislative session
the last session up in carson city that
did not have a veto was back in 2003
with former governor kenny gwynne
a reminder we're going to be in carson
city to cover the last few days of the
legislative session
the itunes david charns will have live
reports sunday and monday when the
session ends
and you can watch all of our coverage
right here on channel 8 and of course on
eight newsnow dot com
in washington nevada congressman stephen
horsford joined fellow democrats in a
meeting with the family of george floyd
it has now been one year since floyd was
murdered by a former minneapolis police
officer derrick chauvin
i'm a parent i have three kids so to
hear
gianna who's seven years old talk about
her dad
and what she wants which is
for him to be remembered around the
world
not because of his death or how he died
but through this passage of the george
floyd justice and policing act
now house lawmakers did pass a police
reform bill however it's
stalled in the senate right now if
approved it would ban
chokeholds and no knock warrants the
measure would also create a national
registry for officers who were
disciplined for serious misconduct
republicans object to changes that allow
individual police officers to be sued
for their actions
i think we're making the kind of
progress that we need to make
that is south carolina senator tim scott
he is the lead negotiator for the
republicans
he says both republicans and democrats
are still trying to work on a compromise
on this issue
nevada though did take steps this week
on no knock warrants
during a breaking down barriers special
right here on eight news now this week
metro police discussed other changes
that have been made in the past year
here's oracle mana
las vegas joining the nation in protest
following the murder of george floyd
one year ago attention quickly turned to
tactics used by metro police
there have been numerous policy changes
and yes they are working while use of
force policies have been updated
two new bills in nevada signed into law
tuesday by governor steve sisilak
take things a step further one allows
the attorney general's office to do
pattern or practice investigations to
see if an issue with law enforcement
is just the isolated actions of one
officer or if it's part of a larger
systemic issue
the other severely limits no knock
warrants so the question
is will this make a difference we're
moving in the right direction because it
is not just a few bad apples
you know sort of that are ruining the
punch but activists add there's more
work to be done
it's a start but we still have we still
have to continue to move it forward
this is not nearly enough this is just
only the beginning
metro understands the road ahead is long
but the department is willing to work
with the community
i couldn't agree more with inviting the
ag's office
into our investigations we're an
organization that is not afraid
of progressive change the goal is to
create an inclusive environment and
honor
george floyd's legacy i hope that that
we continue this track together
orca mana 8 news now you can watch the
full conversation from our breaking down
barriers
special at eight newsnow dot com we
would like to thank again captain yaz
yatomy from metro police
kennedy coleman cobb and richardson and
naacp las vegas chapter president
roxanne mccoy
for joining us for that program you
heard from them in that story there
clark county sheriff joe lombardo has
told 8 news now the no knock warrant
bill only really adopts metro's existing
policy now it is
state law he says that he is glad the
attorney general can now do those
pattern or practice investigations in
nevada well here's a question who will
be nevada's next
governor next on politics now we'll look
at how the field is
shaping up for next year's election
welcome back
to politics now
[Music]
all right let's talk about the race for
nevada governor this week clark county
sheriff joe lombardo confirmed to eight
news now he is running for the job
i can confirm that with you but
unfortunately
we i kind of got caught off a little off
guard
up there in reno but you know that's i
got to be frank with the public
and and i am running for governor um we
we
plan on a formal announcement here in
the next coming weeks
and i will um display or provide my
platform
uh moving forward at that time lombardo
is a republican he first
said that he would run it for governor
officially to a tv station up in reno
which is what he was referring to there
also as you heard lombardo has not
unveiled a platform a political platform
outside of law enforcement he says he's
going to do that in the next couple of
weeks
as for his potential opponents in the
republican field for governor
district 2 congressman mark amaday says
he is still weighing whether or not to
run
amanda told the reno gazette journal he
likes his chances because his district
is where most of nevada's republican
votes lie
amide is known as more of a moderate
republican he was also though the state
chair for the trump campaign in 2020
politico reports former nevada senator
dean heller is considering also
jumping into the governor's race heller
lost his re-election bid
in the senate to jackie rosen in 2018.
while in the senate heller was often one
of the swing votes on key legislation
north las vegas mayor john lee is also
running for governor as a republican
so why do so many republicans think
current democratic governor steve
sislike is vulnerable in the next
election
well look at this back in march the las
vegas review journal had a poll
and it found 48 percent of those who
took part approved of the governor's
performance as governor 43 percent
uh 48 percent of beggar pardon 43
disapproved and 10 were unsure
52 percent approved of his handling of
the coronavirus
those back in march we should point out
next on politics now are wild horses
being
sold for food we're calling it slaughter
gate
it happens about every decade the eye
exposes an investigation into the west's
iconic symbols
being turned into food plus this
lawmakers are taking a look at how to
prevent a devastating wildfire season
like we saw last year
you're watching politics now
[Music]
keeping wildfires from burning through
the west that was the goal of a hearing
in congress this week
the u.s forest service chief says
climate change is fueling more
frequent and more severe wildfires last
year
more federal land burned across the
country than any year since 1910
the crisis results from a changing
climate it induces severe
wildfires droughts insects disease and
invasive species
if we fail fire borrowing will come
roaring back doing major damage
to the forest service
wildfires alex limon from our washington
dc bureau alex
senator merkley from oregon brought up
what he called fire
borrowing what is fire borrowing and
why is it a problem fire borrowing is
something that the
u.s forest service used for many years
to fight
these massive and devastating fires that
we see out west
and that continue to get worse and worse
every year and so
essentially what the forest service
would do is once they ran out of money
in their regular budget to fight these
fires they would
borrow from other parts of their budget
sometimes
well a lot of times frequently from the
parts of the budget that they're
supposed to use
to staff for preventative measures
staff the forest service year around for
example to
clear dry and dead brush and all of the
mechanisms that would prevent
you know these types of wildfires or at
least help to to make them not as severe
the money for that would be gone and so
it would create kind of this endless
cycle that senator merkley says is just
devastating for the forest service
and congress actually approved a fix for
that and they created essentially
um similar to a fema
budget a fema emergency fund for example
so that the forest service could tap
into that money instead
did congress did lawmakers have anything
else or suggest anything else the forest
service can do
to try and help with wildfire prevention
and get ahead of the situation
yeah definitely they concentrated a lot
we heard a little bit about it
in that story on the issue of hiring and
retaining
staff again going back to this idea of
trying to prevent the wildfires or at
least trying to prevent them from
getting so
out of control in the first place and
one of the issues the forest service has
is that they don't have apparently the
staff necessary
year-round to go in and do that
prevention the clearing
that's necessary to get rid of the fuels
that
fuel these fires and again that was alex
limon from washington dc she referenced
staffing another problem is retaining
firefighters
the average forest service firefighter
for example the salary
about thirty five thousand dollars well
from wildfires to wild horses
you know wild horses are a beloved
symbol of the west they're part of the
american landscape
the i-team here at eight news now has
covered wild horses and the issues
surrounding them for years
the i-team's vanessa murphy now tells us
an investigation has revealed some are
being sold for slaughter
you have these like iconic american
you know symbols of freedom that are
being brutally butchered
and shipped off for foreign horse meat
markets overseas
executive director suzanne roy says the
american wild horse campaign teamed up
with the new york times for an in-depth
investigation
which revealed wild horses are being
sold for slaughter
we're calling it slaughter gate it
happens about every decade
the blm gets exposed for sending horses
federally protected wild horses and
burros to slaughter
and the reason this is happening is
because the blm
keeps rounding up wild horses by law the
bureau of land management is authorized
to capture wild horses and boroughs for
the health and productivity of
public lands wild horse advocates point
to cattle ranchers and their interest in
the land for their livestock
in recent years there has been a
record-breaking number of roundups
in some instances causing injuries and
deaths to the animals
the ones that survive are kept in
federal holding pens
through a federal program an individual
is offered one
thousand dollars to adopt one horse
but roy says some people were taking the
money
selling the animals and through the
investigation and tracking
it was discovered some animals were
headed to be killed for human
consumption
it was just horrific and it just breaks
your heart when you see people
under false pretenses say we're going to
adopt a pony
democratic congresswoman dina titus is a
long time advocate for wild horses
according to the blm as of march 2020
there were nearly 47 thousand wild
horses in this state
that's more than half of all the wild
horses in the country
congresswoman titus and roy say they
support a method of birth control
through
darts for the animals advocates say it's
more cost effective
and more humane than roundups but so far
the blm
has shown resistance we've never come up
with somebody
in the blm who really cares about this
and i think now
secretary holland will be the person who
can be a good partner for
us the i-team's request for an interview
with the new secretary of interior who
oversees the blm
was declined the american wild horse
campaign is now calling for an
investigation into the adoption program
it wants employees held accountable
criminal prosecution for those who sold
the animals for slaughter
and for lawmakers to step in
congresswoman titus says
gradually there is more interest in
legislation
but there is also a challenge sometimes
it's hard to get through
the agriculture committee though because
it's so dominated
by ranching interests vanessa murphy 8
news now
congresswoman titus says she receives
the most amount of letters about this
issue of the wild horses
people from all over the country she
says show support for wild horses even
if they've never actually seen one in
person
in what to watch we're keeping an eye on
the final days of the legislative
session
will attacks on mining companies pay for
education will it get passed
that could be one of the trades to have
some extra money into state coffers plus
how will different how different will
elections look in 2021
we're watching a handful of bills that
could drastically change how nevada does
elections including one to make us a
primary and jump us to
first in the country and as you
mentioned earlier we're going to be in
carson city to cover the end of the
legislative session
the i-team's david charns will have live
reports tomorrow and on monday
until the session ends you can watch all
of our coverage right here on channel 8
and of course on eight newsnow dot com
with that we thank you very much for
watching us here on politics now
stay up to date online at
eightnewsnow.com we'll be back with you
next saturday
[Music]
you